number three in our top photos we're in
Armenia over six thousand demonstrators
protest steep increase in electricity
prices in the capital city of Yerevan
police used water cannons to break up
the protests more than 230 demonstrators
and journalists have been detained in
the most widespread public
demonstrations since 2013 and we're at
the central bank governor Kazakhstan
later on yeah and Brendan you'd be great
on this protest don't make the headlines
around Europe it is just part of that
diminished real economy of a greater
eurasian time economic conditions matter
economists say reduce subsidies fuel
subsidies or bad energy subsidies are
bad they certainly are over the long run
in the short run it's what people and
democracies pay attention to you take
away a subsidy politically very painful
economist can't ignore Paul great photo
there from lexi what else to give number
two Pakistan the heat wave has people
cooling off in the arabian sea
temperatures in the hardest hit area
Karachi have reached 111 degrees this
week nearly 200 people have died so far
Pakistani official said and the
government is cold in the army to tackle
the widespread heat stroke in India a
few weeks ago got rain finally right
though ah well sir Bombay has too much
rain inconceivable all right Nolan after
severe thunderstorms across the
Northeast last night beautiful sunsets
made the weather worth it sunset over
Boston from Fenway Park especially for
You Tom during the game between the
Boston Red Sox in the baltimore orioles
baltimore 164 sunset over new york city
next sun sun set over washington DC if
we can get those in there is new york
city wait in that wait to whom does the
does the copyright on that picture
belong i believe it is one Lexie 11 on
that picture oh we forgot to put happy
birds no filters Bloomberg surveillances
photo editor Lexie 11 took that picture
she's saying that she wishes of my ear
hold on send the check to who ok there
it is great shot great shot